really a friend to all is a friend to
none yeah yeah I learned that when our
body of my died you drowned
it was tragic and I was at the hospital
and his mother comes and she's you know
and then and then the dad came and
nobody was around to tell him and I was
like [ __ ] freaking out cuz I was like
yeah yeah yeah you know but then I
realized I was like I didn't spend
enough time with this person who was my
true friend
busy busy trying to like be friends with
so many people I was like you don't
gotta give people energy in high school
this guy Eric Purvis he died in a
helicopter accident and I went to San
Diego to his funeral and I realize when
I was driving down there it was like
yeah I haven't talked to this guy you
know because you know you life happens
yeah but I must really love this guy or
is the memory of him we had a really
good memories going on it you know and
there is love there and that's the way
like how Bobby had to taught me so mine
drown yeah well I had this other friend
it was a meteorite shower his name is
kal-el did you know I'm so glad you
brought that up he does some really
gross [ __ ] like this
we were watching America's Got Talent
baby don't bring this story up some
break you know something out of here
alright some b-boys were on there and he
was like look how good they are and I
was like yeah they're alright I was like
you should see my friend who's a real
b-boy he travels all over the rest of
Korea right
well he's jealous cuz you know what I do
what I showed him and the guy
spectacular my friend is spectacular you
know he's alright
he turns around he goes he's alright you
know it's so weird I'm really good
friends with I forget what they're
called at the job a walker
show the ones he said he said I think
they're called a Jabberwock oh I I you
know I yeah I did ten I switched the
Dave so it seemed like I don't even care
to remember eyes that's how cool I am
you know that's how [ __ ] gross it was
yeah I just I just don't like people
one-upping me man
and I was showing her I love British Got
Talent I was showing her a [ __ ] b-boy
group that got you know they were all
right and then she goes look at my
friends well if you're on a show like
that you're just all right anyway